et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Franck Riester bonjour bonjour Thibault
d'être avec des relations avec le
Parlement on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Jefferson des sports du
Sud-Ouest aujourd'hui faire ça bonjour
Oriane bonjour on va évidemment parler
de ce qui s'est passé hier à l'Assemblée
Franck Riester ambiance plus électrique
lors de l'examen de la proposition de
l'ayotte en commission la majorité a
réussi à supprimer l'article qui
annulait les 64 ans la gauche a quitté
la commission elle a parlé de magouille
avant de parler du fond est-ce que la
séquence d'hier est ravageuse pour
l'image du Parlement
c'est un on le sait c'est un sujet qui
est un peu électrique
mais il y a eu un travail en commission
il y a eu un vote et je tiens à rappeler
qu'il y ait eu un vote avec une majorité
de députés en commission qui ont
effectivement supprimé cet article 1 qui
abrogeait le report de l'âge légal de
départ en retraite les oppositions et
notamment la nupes ont du mal avec le
vote et accepter le vote mais il y a eu
un vote après effectivement les
pressions les menaces l'agitation des
députés qui viennent en plus pour mettre
de la pression créer de la tension
dépression par la majorité
présidentielle elle a raison de le dire
elle était en commission de la nupesse
ou Boyard a été pas de s'agiter moi j'ai
regardé ça par vidéo j'étais pas présent
donc il faut mieux interroger
précisément ce qui était présent mais on
voit bien que les témoignages de ce qui
nous sont rapportés de la députés de la
majorité c'est clairement une pression
très forte et leur pas que de la
majorité puisque pour cogner une
majorité en commission à travers le vote
il faut qu'il y ait des députés hors de
la majorité présidentielle qui est votée
aussi la suppression de l'article 1 et
notamment un certain nombre de députés
LR dont je salue le courage et la
cohérence par rapport à leurs idées
voilà et on peut regretter les 3000 sous
amendements déposés parce que le vote ne
convient pas à la nupes ne convient pas
monsieur de Courson et à Monsieur
pencher et à ce moment-là on dépose plus
de 3000 sous amendements qui ont pas été
examinés
c'est une c'est une farce dire on est on
est sérieux la politique c'est vrai que
ça l'image du Parlement et à la façon
dont on doit travailler au Parlement
quand on est des députés qu'on dépose
des amendements pour travailler en
commission il y en a 56 de déposer et
que d'un seul coup parce qu'il y a un
vote qui vous plaît pas vous voulez
bloquer le travail en commission en
déposant plus de 3000 sous amendements
vous comprenez bien qu'on va pas qu'il
faudrait des heures des dizaines
d'heures pour étudier
3000 sous amendements donc on voit bien
que c'était pour bloquer le système la
présidente de et le bureau de la
commission et raison de dire stop on
peut pas accepter ces sous amendements
là il y a eu jusqu'au bout du process
pour qu'il y a un vote et puis il y aura
un débat le 8 sur ces questions
justement mais en attendant en attendant
mais les critiques sont féroces contre
la majorité aujourd'hui et pendant la
séance en commission n'a-t-il pas nous a
dénoncé une macronie en dérive mafieuse
les mots ont été très forts on vous
reproche de refuser la démocratie de
refuser l'obstacle de ne pas aller au
vote dans l'hémicycle parce que le vote
a été bloqué en commission est-ce que ça
c'était la bonne stratégie et je reviens
sur la question de pourquoi vous dit sur
l'image pourquoi vous dites que le vote
a été bloqué en commission le vote
l'article 1 qui devait aller à
l'hémicycle a été supprimé a été bloquée
en commission par un vote vous l'avez
dit mais en tout cas vous n'êtes pas
allé jusqu'au vote dans l'hémicycle
c'est le reproche qui vous êtes sur
Public Sénat ici c'est la Chaîne
parlementaire du Sénat vous savez à quel
point
le travail législatif au Parlement passe
par la Commission et passe par la même
taille de procédure mais non c'est un
mais non c'est un travail législatif il
y a un texte qui est présenté par
l'opposition qui vient débattu dans en
commission il y a un des articles qui
repoussé par une majorité de députés en
commission mais c'est tous les jours que
ça fonctionne comme ça donc il y a pas
de tentative de bloquer des bas il y a
des bas c'est pas il y a pas de volonté
de bloquer un texte il y a un vote et un
travail législatif qui fait que oui il y
a une majorité de députés qui veut pas
revenir sur une réforme qui a été votée
on est bien d'accord c'est le fait le
point c'est de respecter le travail
parlementaire on verra ensuite quels
amendements sont déposés entre la
Commission et la séance voir quels sont
les sujets qui seront débattus on verra
si les amendements qui sont déposés sont
recevables ou pas quand j'entends madame
panot effectivement qui dit que la
macronie c'est les dérives mafieuses
mais moi je trouve que les insoumis sont
dans une dérive de plus en plus
factieuse parce que contestée en
permanence la Constitution contester le
fonctionnement des assemblées par
exemple l'article 40 qui dit que on ne
peut pas recevoir si il y a pas une
sorte de consensus entre parlementaires
avec le gouvernement sur un une charge
qui est créée et bien elle est
inconstitutionnelle c'est pas compliqué
tous les jours sur les amendements sur
les projets loin sur les propositions
loi qui sont
de la commission des finances n'aurait
pas dû déclarer cette proposition va
recevoir
mon avis depuis le départ c'est que bien
sûr que ça crée une charge pardon c'est
15 mill par an qui n'est pas financé ça
crée une charge qui oui à partir du
moment où il y a pas de consensus être
quelque chose qui n'est pas recevable ça
tombe sur votre proposition de loi sur
le Bien Vieillir ça crée aussi une
charge
et qui avait un consensus qu'on s'insus
très large à l'Assemblée et qu'on
s'insus avec le gouvernement qui donc
couvre effectivement cette charge et
considère que on peut aller jusqu'au
bout du processus mais c'est ça le
depuis 1950
tous les observateurs tous les les
constitutionnalisme sont d'accord sur le
fait que de dire que cette création de
charge massive tombe sur le coup de
l'article 40
de l'Assemblée nationale s'il revient si
l'article 1 revient sous la forme d'un
amendement parce que là et pour le coup
c'est le scénario finalement on verra
qu'il allait le redéposer sous forme
j'ai pas de doute que la présidente de
jambes et nationale assurance est
responsabilités nous verrons
n’anticipons pas je sais que parfois
certains ont tendance à mettre la
charrue avant les deux mais attendons le
processus ça veut dire quoi assumer sa
responsabilité ça veut dire le déclarer
recevable cet amendement nous verrons je
vais pas prendre la décision à la place
de la prison de l'Assemblée nationale
c'est elle qui prendra cette décision
puisque c'est elle qui est en charge de
déclarer la recevabilité dans le cadre
de l'article 40 des amendements qui sont
présentés pour la séance sans demande de
l'exécutif sans demande de la première
ministre puisqu'elle a déjà déclaré
recevable une première fois
donc si elle change de pied ça veut dire
moi je suis assez sidéré de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui dans le débat public
et moi je suis j'ai des chefs
d'entreprise j'ai été maire pendant 10
ans je suis lu depuis 2016 je vois une
dégradation du débat public notamment
avec cette cette façon de travestir la
réalité c'est fake news ces infox cette
façon de de présenter une vérité qui
vous arrange au contraire de la réalité
des choses ça a pas été déclaré
recevable au bureau mais c'est le dépôt
depuis 1958 ans au Sénat à l'Assemblée
il y a une tradition qui fait que au
moment du dépôt de proposition de loi
quelle que soit l'origine de la de du
groupe politique qui dépose la
proposition de loi il y a une
recevabilité automatique au moment du
dépôt mais il y a des centaines de
propositions de loi qui sont déposés
sans jamais être difficultés et le
règlement de l'Assemblée nationale
prévoit à partir du moment où le texte
est inscrit pour être débattu pour être
éventuellement voté à ce moment-là il y
a une deuxième un deuxième filtre de
recevabilité et c'est là que se joue
exactement la recevabilité dans le cas
de l'article 40 et donc il y a El Brown
Pivet et le bureau parce que c'est même
pas elle personnellement c'est le bureau
de l'Assemblée nationale par délégation
qui automatiquement
accepte le dépôt des propositions loi
quelle qu'elle soit même si
au moment où elles sont inscrits pour
débat sont jugés irrecevables sur le
cadre de l'article 49 et donc vous voyez
on a j'ai entendu plein de gens dire
elle a changé d'avis à la retourner sa
veste il y a eu des pressions de
l'exécutif j'entendais un député LR sur
une télévision hier dire qu'elle avait
reçu des Melun c'est de pression comme
quoi si elle ne faisait pas exactement
ce que les équipes qui fument demandait
elle le serait sorti de la majorité mais
c'est mal connaître il y avait LeBron
Pinet et c'est mal connaître exécutif on
respecte nos députés de la majorité
comme de l'opposition et je peux vous
dire qu'en tant que ministre en charge
des relations avec le Parlement les
relations avec la présidente de la
Surmont national sont très fluides sont
très bonnes pas du tout dans un état
d'esprit de menace on est
respectueux de l'Assemblée nationale et
elle est respectueuse de son allégé sur
les LR franchiseur ce que vous l'avez
évoqué en préambule les LR ont modifié
leur composition leur présence au sein
de la commission ils ont sorti une
députée qui avait voté la motion de
censure pour la remplacer par une autre
députée plus favorable à votre réforme
des retraites est-ce que vous y voyez un
signe est-ce que ça veut dire qu'avec
les LR il y a un retour du à la normale
on va dire en tout cas une discussion un
peu plus fluide en tout cas c'est pas
neutre ce qui s'est passé je vais vous
dire et aucun je pense des dirigeants
DLR pourront dire que les relations que
j'entretiens avec les LR ou que la
première ministre entretien claire ne
sont pas fluides on discute
régulièrement et d'ailleurs pas qu'un
raison
avec les oppositions constructives je
suis en discussion permanente et en ce
qui concerne spécifiquement les LR je
discute avec Olivier Marleix le
président du groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale avec Bruno Retailleau ici le
président du groupe au Sénat avec les
dirigeants avec les députés les
sénateurs LR tous les jours d'une façon
très fluide et en ce qui concerne
Justine Gruet la députée donc on vous
parlez elle a elle-même expliqué ce
qu'il en était et qu'elle ne supportait
pas que certains parlent pour elle elle
s'est exprimée en disant que on pouvait
être favorable à la motion la beauté de
censure sur le texte quand il s'était
agit de voter la motion de censure sur
le texte à l'Assemblée nationale et être
défavorable à cette PP Elliott et
qu'elle s'est fait remplacer parce
qu'elle ne pouvait pas être présente en
commission non pas parce que elle
n'était pas en ligne avec le vote de
celle qui l'a remplacé donc vous voyez
tout ça aussi c'est de la désinformation
et la manipulation parce que parce que
vous dites-vous mais ce qui est relayé
par les oppositions qui ne supporte pas
qu'il y ait eu un et que
naturellement les choses se déroulent
comme elles de se déroule classiquement
sur n'importe quel texte avec des textes
qui sont déposés des votes qui parfois
repoussent des articles et pour autant
qu'ils ne remettent absolument pas en
cause ni le droit de l'opposition ni la
parole du Parlement bien au contraire
puisque vous parlez de motion de censure
Bertrand penchere qui était à votre
place en début de semaine une exclut pas
de déposer une motion de censure est-ce
que ce serait justifié pour vous
c'est lui de prendre sa responsabilité
c'est pas la première motion de censure
qui serait déposée à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a une nombreuses reprises
elles ont toutes été rejetées on verra
ce qui s'il y a une notion censure ce
que sera le résultat ce que sera le
résultat mais écoutez là aussi je vais
pas faire de la politique fiction ce qui
est certain c'est que je suis aussi très
choqué des propos de Bertrand pencher
avec qui j'entretiens des relations
fluides là j'avoue que son ce qui dit
sur ce qui se passe au Parlement
aujourd'hui
m'étonne et c'est un faible mot
quand il dit que il y a un blocage
de du Parlement mais c'est faux il y a
pas de blocage du Parlement quand
j'entends les commentateurs je vous dis
des éditorialistes dire la même chose
hier sur l'échelle ah là là ce qui s'est
passé hier c'est le démontre le blocage
du Parlement mais où il bloquace il y a
un texte qui vient qui discuter il y a
des votes le texte continue mais il y a
eu un vote mais le 8 juin il risque de
ne pas y avoir de vote mais pourquoi
vous dit est-ce que ça est-ce que ça
pour le ministre des Relations avec le
Parlement
qui est pas de vote sur la sur le la
commission sur le texte qui va aller en
discussion dans l'hémicycle bien sûr
qu'il y aura un vote si le si les liotes
maintiennent à l'ordre du jour de la
niche parlementaire du 8 juin leur texte
bah il sera discuté il y aura un vote
alors sur la base de ce qui a été décidé
en commission plus
il y a eu un vote pour ça
blocage quand j'entends le blocage du
Parlement mais c'est complètement faux
il y a eu encore deux votes hier à pour
certains
à l'Assemblée nationale on en est je
crois à 34 textes votés depuis le début
de la législature tant d'origine
parlementaire que d'origine
gouvernementale avec des réformes
ambitieuses et dans ces 34 volts il y a
eu que trois utilisations du 49-3 pour
voter ses textes tout le reste c'est des
majorités plus larges que la majorité
présidentielle parce que
la volonté de la première nuit ça a été
respectée c'est-à-dire du dialogue de la
recherche de compromis et d'aller
chercher des majorités plus larges
le Parlement avance la loi de
programmation militaire qui devrait être
votée aujourd'hui ou demain non c'est
aujourd'hui on est jeudi le temps passe
vite assez se passe dans un climat de
dialogue et d'échanges remarquable et
c'est fondamental pour la défense pour
nos armées pour les 6 ans qui viennent
vous pensez qu'elle sera votée parce
qu'Olivier Marleix nous disait que les
députés LR n'étaient pas sur de la
beauté on verra mais je sens qu'il y a
globalement un travail constructif qui
est fait avec un gouvernement à l'écoute
Sébastien le cor la défense a fait un
trail remarquable avec les groupes pour
permettre qu'on ne puisse avoir un vote
je j'étais dans l'hémicycle avant-hier
sur cette loi de programmation militaire
je vois l'ambiance qui est bonne le
travail qui est riche les
le la participation des oppositions
constructives et utiles puisque le texte
est amendé dans leur sens dans un
syndrome de cas c'est ça le travail
parlementaire et ça va permettre de
doter nos armées de moyens considérables
pour les 5-6 ans qui viennent on va
parler de la suite
là est-ce que vous demandez aux
oppositions de reconnaître leur défaite
après ce qui s'est passé en commission
parce que vous n'en sortez pas et l'idée
c'est quand même de prolonger ce débat
de l'étirer au maximum écouter moi je
dis simplement que les Français
attendent que le Parlement fait ce sont
face à son travail il y a beaucoup de
sujets qui doivent être abordés il y a
un nord du jour très riche si je sens du
travail législatif c'est pas de remettre
l'ouvrage sur le métier sans arrêt
autre chose mais pourquoi ça laisserait
il y avait beaucoup de tensions
notamment par exemple Eric non mais par
exemple les ricoquerelle qu'il a déclaré
tête de la commission des continents
avec le Parlement de décider à la place
des députés de qui en temps
responsabilité dans tel ou telle
fonction
chaque année il y a le renouvellement
des prénoms de commission il y a les
roulements du bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale les députés prendront leur
décision c'est pas à moi de juger
simplement j'en ai j'avoue je suis
surpris et même lassé de voir que
certains relais des fake news des
contrevérités alors même que le travail
au Parlement continue que détecte son
votés que là il y a eu un vote même si
ça plaît pas à ceux qui voulaient le
vote et un résultat différent c'est ça
la démocratie et je vois certains
notamment les insoumis qui font plutôt
de la démagogie que de la démocratie et
donc j'aimerais que pour que nos
compatriotes retrouvent une image plus
positive du Parlement on retrouve
sérénité et qu'on accepte de respecter
les règles qui sont les nôtres et qu'on
ne travestisse pas la réalité des faits
qui sont très claires celles que ceux
que j'ai essayé de rappeler ce matin on
va parler de la suite du travail
parlementaire le projet de loi
immigration est-ce qu'il y aura un texte
présenté en Conseil des ministres au
mois de juillet la première ministre a
dit encore aujourd'hui qui aurait une
discussion à l'automne sur sur cette
question là le moment
après il y a une question de dépôt de
vous savez comment fonctionne le
processus législatif il y a des
discussions il y a la rédaction d'un
texte il y a le dépôt de la présentation
du texte en conseil des ministres et
ensuite il y a une inscription à
l'agenda bon il y aura discussion à
l'automne sur un texte immigration
c'était très compliqué il y a eu des
remirements toutes ces dernières
semaines c'était on oublie le texte on
n'a pas de majorité pour le voter dans
la feuille de route et puis tout d'un
coup c'est revenu donc concrètement on
en est où pour faire simple Franck
Esther vous voyez bien que mais c'est
pas un sujet simple si c'était un sujet
simple ça serait bon voilà donc c'est
pas un sujet simple c'est un sujet qui
nécessite de la discussion qui nécessite
de s'écouter de se parler de trouver des
voies de passage des compromis ce qui
est là ce que nous souhaitons c'est
qu'un certain nombre de points très
concrets très opérationnel qui méritent
d'être pris en compte avec une
modification de la législation puisse
être pris à travers un texte de loi pour
mieux lutter contre les passeurs mieux
lutter contre les marchands de de vie
humaine mieux faire en sorte que les
procédures soient simplifiées soit
simple que les délaiss soient plus
courts parce que c'est l'intérêt non
seulement de la politique migratoire que
nous voulons faire mais aussi de celles
et ceux qui que nous accueillons c'est
pas plus compliqué que ça et donc je
pense que nous pouvons partager un
constat avec un certain nombre de forces
politiques partager un certain nombre de
propositions comme le propos Gérald
Darmanin pour remédier à ses
problématiques là et ensuite d'avoir un
texte qui de rassembler une majorité
plus large la majorité présidentielle
gens avec les parlementaires est-ce que
vous avez déjà commencé à discuter avec
les LR la première ministre a confié la
responsabilité de la négociation en
Gérald Darmanin en lien avec Olivier moi
les discussions ont commencé elles se
avec la majorité elles vont se
poursuivre et je recommençais à se
poursuivre avec les différents
dirigeants des oppositions c'est Gérald
Darmanin qui est à la nouvelle qui est
en Nouvelle-Calédonie de le faire et le
moment venu on verra ce que sera le
fruit de ces discussions et quel texte
sur le est présenté pour faire avancer
ces questions là sur quoi vous pouvez
avancer parce que chaque camp a posé des
lignes rouges on pourrait parler de la
Constitution que les LR veulent modifier
revenir sur la primauté des droits
européens on pourrait revenir sur l'ame
qui là aussi est une ligne rouge ils
veulent les l'herbe le transformer en
aide médicale d'urgence bref sur quoi
vous pouvez avancer et trouver un
compromis Franck d'éléments très
factuels qui permettent de répondre aux
problématiques de nos compatriotes et de
celles et ceux qui sont accueillis dans
notre pays sur les que j'ai évoqué tout
à l'heure mais vous savez
si on veut qui est un compromis il faut
que chacun fasse des efforts c'est pas
chacun reste
bloqué sur ces positions
et ensuite il y a un travail de toute
façon au Parlement avec des
modifications entre le texte qui est
présenté par le gouvernement et celui
qui est voté le moment venu sur la
régularisation des métiers en tension je
vais pas vous dire quels sont les fruits
des discussions et des éventuelles
avancées réciproque ce qui compte c'est
d'être dans un état d'esprit constructif
je vous le rappelle plus de 30 textes
qui ont été votés depuis le début de la
législature avec cette méthode là
d'écoute de modification de recherche de
compromis de consensus pour avancer pour
répondre concrètement problématiques de
nos compatriotes sur tous les sujets et
notamment sur le sujet l'immigration et
moi j'appelle à tous celles et ceux qui
ont envie de régler un certain nombre de
points problématiques de se retrouver
sur des diagnostics partagés et des
mesures concrètes qu'on peut mettre en
application et pourrait être partagé
également c'est pas plus compliqué que
ça mais il y a un travail à conduire ce
travail s'est produit par Gérald
Darmanin autre sujet Gabriel Attal a
présenté deux plans un plan de lutte
contre la fraude fiscale un plan de
lutte contre la fraude sociale est-ce
qu'il y aura des traductions
législatives rapides
il y aura des traductions dans le
l'organisation des services ça a été
expliqué par Gabriel Attal et pourrait y
avoir une partie de traduction dans les
projets de loi de finances dans les
projets de web finance de la sécurité
sociale vous savez qui a été voté qui a
été il a été il a été voté un projet loi
sur les doigts ici au Sénat d'une façon
très large là aussi
encore une démonstration que quand un
texte est bien préparé par le ministre
quand il y a des réponses concrètes aux
problématiques de nos compatriotes il y
a il peut y avoir un consensus très
large et notamment au Sénat et donc ce
projet doit douane donne plus de moyens
à la douane permet de mieux travailler
aux équipes de la douane et donc
notamment à lutter contre un certain
nombre de trafic il y aura pas de
projets de loi spécifique sur ces plans
je sais pas
[Musique]
plus par la première année Gabriel Attal
justement si on reste sur les impôts et
les finances Emmanuel Macron a promis à
annoncé 2 milliards d'impôts de baisse
d'impôts en moins pour les classes
moyennes comment on va rendre ça visible
Franck Chrysler parce que 200 milliards
d'impôts en moins pour ces classes
moyennes c'est presque c'est un peu
moins de la moitié c'est même un peu
plus de la moitié qu'est-ce qu'il y
avait déjà été fait sous le présent
qu'un canard on avait 4 à 5 milliards
d'euros de baisse là on est à moitié
moins comment on rend ça visible parce
que ça ça pourrait être un joli
casse-tête oui bon on va regarder les
modalités mais ce qui compte c'est
l'ambition faire en sorte que nos
compatriotes et davantage de pouvoir
d'achat que faire en sorte que nos
compatriotes qui travaillent puissent
mieux vivre c'est ça notre
obsessions et que ceux qui travaillent
gagnent davantage c'est ça c'est pour ça
qu'on a fait la prime Macron c'est pour
ça qu'on a baissé dans le quinquennat
précédent l'impôt sur le revenu que nous
voulons continuer à baisser les impôts
sur ces classes moyennes celles et ceux
qui travaillent et qui aujourd'hui
parfois ont pas suffisamment pour vivre
comme il devrait c'est pour ça que nous
avons non mais attendez c'est important
notre obsession c'est laisser la
fiscalité dans ce pays nous sommes le
pays qui fiscalise le plus de tous les
pays de l'OCDE à part le Danemark pas
par idéologie par stratégie stratégie
d'achat pour les particuliers et
stratégies de compétitivité pour nos
entreprises et donc pour l'économie
française et ça marche puisque vous
travaillez sur la question de la
sénatoriales avec notamment marcéno pour
le modèle mais avec Karis Bournazel pour
horizon est-ce qu'il y aura des
candidats communs de la majorité
présidentielle partout et est-ce que le
fait que Renaissance réinvestisse et
sortant n'est pas un point bloquant non
c'est pas un point commun c'est un
principe qui me paraît bon quand vous
avez des troupes dans un parti politique
qui sont loyaux loyal pardon c'est trop
qui
représente avec beaucoup de
détermination de loyauté et de force la
majorité présidentielle le projet du
gouvernement et du président de la
République on les soutient et c'est ce
que nous faisons candidats qu'il le soit
évidemment ceux qui le souhaitent auront
l'investiture de renaissance et nous
travaillons avec nos partenaires dans
tous les départements pour trouver les
soutiens pour identifier les celles et
ceux que nous allons soutenir
pour ces élections sénatoriales les
discussions se passent très bien doit se
revoir encore prochainement et le moment
venu vous verrez que la majorité
présidentielle est au travail pour
préparer les élections quelles qu'elles
soient et notamment les scénarios avec
un objectif combien de sénateurs
possibles
si on prend les régionales les
municipales etc ça ne réussit pas à
cette majorité présidentielle donc quels
sont les objectifs pour venir le mode de
scrutin et vous savez que ce sont les
grands électeurs ce sont les élus qui
votent pour les sénateurs nous avons eu
des résultats
au départemental
plus que mitigé et bien vous avez un
corps électoral qui est ce qu'il est et
donc nous devons faire avec ce corps
électoral avec une volonté c'est qu'on
est le plus de sénateurs de la majorité
présidentielle ou qui soutiennent
l'action du gouvernement et qui est qui
soit bienveillant avec l'action du
gouvernement merci Franck merci merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité merci
de Jefferson on passe sur le détail